this is pretty simple stuff let me say  that again  this is pretty simple stuff  you get the head of the progressive  caucus  you get  joe mansion  and you get  joe biden  and you put him in a room  and you say we're not going to get out  of this room until one of two things  happen  one we have a deal  or two  we're gonna have a press conference  where we go out and announce that joe  manchin does not support any piece of  legislation  regarding buildback better he we either  have a bill or joe manchin will never  support anything and he's been lying to  us for the past year and a half it's  very clear and my god i just wonder what  would have happened if progressives have  gotten their six trillion dollar wish  earlier this year  yeah in an ironic way you almost have to  thank joe manchin for blocking that i  wouldn't even say ironically thank joe  mancha you can just thank joe manchin  if  you're glad that interest rates aren't  even higher